you say like okay so those are our
favorites guy might have idea what we
just did a lightning round going there
great case there's a lot we didn't
mention that we loved but is what almost
the end of June so we have six months to
pull through seven months if you count
don't you it all it's one blur man I
don't know anyway what time was it
February when monster hunter world came
out and that kind of caught me by
surprise notwithstanding three hours I
put in the monster hundred three I think
mantra kana world's my first monster
hunter I know mother on the world my
first watch your honor and I approve
loved it
[Music]
we talked about a lot about how it kind
of supplanted destiny for a lot of
people in that lifestyle game genre
River USA what that has daily events and
it's kind of designed to come back to it
I absolutely love Monster Honor I think
it respected my time a lot more than a
lot of those other games do and I also
thought that it it gave me a reason to
actually feel good about grinding I
wasn't actually just doing stuff for
nothing which I absolutely loved the
combat I love how in-depth and how much
control they give me as far as I'm like
like my character is developing I
absolutely love so much about it I like
I kind of fallen off of it over the last
couple months and I want to go back but
from what I've heard they've been kind
of updating post relation really well
and I think that's kind of been the
highlight of the year for me so far it's
like the big imposing monsters was the
thing for me and I guess they keep
introducing new ones but this time it
felt like at that point I had sort of
exhausted a lot but that was after 40
hours of playing the game which was also
like my first one yeah it literally got
as far as the character creator but and
I was so intimidated by that like like
character creators really really deep as
much that's better because it's really
good yeah and then like even past that
like obviously Monster Hunter the draw
being you are crafting based on what you
kill and then just the amount like this
year I know this sounds basic to anybody
but playing a lot of Monster Hunter but
for my first one need the direct
correlation between what I did and how
it appears in my character and how I
have to forge the show for it is some of
the most satisfying loot grind almost
seems like a bad word but nobody's
accurate though because you're not
guaranteed to get the stuff you want
right it's real tough right you can do
things to enhance your favor your hands
your luck
so hopefully you get what you need which
is nice silver that is I don't you
played a decent on a monster hunter
world but what other games did you like
so far this year oh man I think the one
that is stuck with me the most part of
the forest
on the surface it seems like another
survival game and normally I play those
for a little bit move on because there's
so many out there but this actually
subverts your expectation quite a bit
there's actually a story to it which is
not I wouldn't say the best but the way
it's told is super fascinating an
interest
plus you can play with friends so
there's like this day-to-day goals that
you need to do like eat build shelter
fight off these creepy looking cannibal
things but then there's also this sort
of underground cave system that almost
feels like a Metroidvania game and that
as you explore these caves you find
different items which you can then use
to explore different parts of these
caves which will allow you to unlock the
ending the way all that works together
and kind of mixing horror with the
survival genre plus like this sort of
underground cave system is really smart
and it's a lot of fun especially when
you have a friend to go with you yeah
we're gonna mention the co-op it's kind
of a weird shout but using people that
might be anticipating fallout 76 could
get a little bit out of the forest in
terms of scratching that edge
I think so yeah I think if you're really
looking forward to fallout 76 this is
definitely something worth giving it
giving a try it seems simple at first
maybe not simply be simple is the right
word but it seems OneNote like you're
like alright I get this this is like a
realistic Minecraft or whatever but
there is much more to the story not as
much creativity and customization is
there in Minecraft and other survival
games but I think there's enough there
to keep people invested and hopefully
finish through the campaign or the story
does the coop like would you recommend
that over playing alone I'd be terrified
to play that alone I would be absolutely
terrified to play that game alone cuz
okay let's see that well in the caves
you have a lighter and when you're by
yourself this sound design is also
excellent so you hear all these weird
creepy noises your lighter goes out and
all of a sudden you're just in pitch
black you just hear all these things
running around you
it is terrifying I don't think I could
do it by myself all right antenna then
they released there's not too much time
to deny think all of us played and
really liked God of War but you reviewed
it and you were the first one in the
office to really say this is really
something special yeah and I totally
recognize that a lot of people love this
game because it's like look what they
did with God of War I can see that that
they've transformed it into something
but I think that's almost just sort of
underselling they just like how great it
is on its own terms regardless of what
Kratos was before or not I mean this is
a brooding guy who sort of represents
what a lot of you game characters have
been for ever and sort of shows him in a
really vulnerable state you know with
the kid who himself like kind of echoes
what his father goes through and he's
who were on a journey together in a
beautiful dangerous world that can
actually be kind of haunting in some
ways like I was really surprised by when
you're you know fighting the elf captain
inside of that place where it's a gall
shadow and you have to like he'll pop
into the light there's a really
wonderful range of settings and
environments but also the combat was
great too
I know so many people talk about the the
no cut you know they keep it cameras
over craters his shoulder kind of
getting that like Resident Evil years of
war by Birdman
Birdman well maybe not that one angle
but the yeah the no cut thing and that
was all super impressive and obviously
having that axe was great as well like a
small touch in some other game that
could just feels really amazing here
my favorite part had to be Mamere though
on your belt yeah yeah I think one of
the things that God of War does really
well is companions that aren't annoying
yeah like I think
Mamere I really enjoyed his stories like
I actually stayed in the boat to hear
him talk you know I arrived lot like I
would sit in the boat and just like
listen to him and at Reyes I don't think
I've bonded with a character the way I
did with him so quickly in a really long
time like he's just he's complex and I
he is my son and I love him and I was
killed for him about to yes in the way
that's implemented in combat it's so
smooth like it's so well done yeah
especially seeing the way he grows it's
funny like he grows like in terms of
combat like he has stone tree you can
upgrade but he also like starts to grow
narrative for sure the apples in the
voice yeah which has yet to happen but
yeah I think like I think maybe not to
speak for everyone in the world but I
think that's probably the frontrunner
for a lot about 'lets game of the year
it sounds like so far yeah yeah Kelly
what have you been playing a lot later
what stuck with you so far this year in
addition to God of War I really like
Florence
[Music]
that game is is really something special
it's really short I played it in one
sitting and you have to play with music
and Lee if you don't play with music I
think the impact is diminished just
because the music is so beautiful and
haunting it's very relatable like it
tells the story of a relationship dying
essentially and like how that impacts
the character of Florence and her hopes
and dreams in her life I cried a lot
[Music]
there's no dialogue right there's
there's when you do dialogue you kind of
put these puzzle pieces together and at
first there when you first meet him it's
really hard to there's like five pieces
or something to make up the speech
bubble and as the relationship
progresses you get to like three and
then two and then one yeah and I thought
that was a really powerful and simple
way to just portray how their
relationship grows so it's like easier
to talk to him yeah that's the early
yeah like you mentioned the music I
still throw it on sometimes on Spotify
just to listen to a lot writing
we were going to a trip at a studio do
Rainbow six stuff if I go I'll try this
out like in our hotel when I first
landed I was like I expect it to just
play it and forget about it but like oh
my god between the art style the music
it just stuck with me like it's pretty
sad it's really I mean very relatable
but it's still really tragic it's really
sad it captures the bittersweet aspects
of relationships really well like the
the first scene of like their first
fight is is really I don't know like
it's just the chapters just called
groceries yeah and there's in the
grocery store and the fight just breaks
out it I it it was a lot there let's
deal with the other part of that just
that really stuck me was when I I don't
wanna spoil because you should play this
it's like take like me an hour it took
me maybe 40 minutes yeah there's a part
where you like there's a part that
involves moving that really just in
terms of like basic gameplay creating
emotion was pretty wrenching emotionally
it was tough I thought the moving in
sequence it was and just yeah the moving
sequences were really well done yeah I
don't want to spoil that yeah and then
like you said I took like it takes like
45 minutes another game that you can do
in bite-sized increments although I
think he'll devote more time to it if
you like it like I did I absolutely
loved into the breach from the team that
made FTL faster than light and also been
front II came back to do the music I
absolutely love turn-based strategy
games into the breach is like chess
almost where you have to think 10 steps
ahead it's not as reactionary although
like stuff will happen you're pretty
much trying to you're on this I think
it's a 12 by 12 grid that might be give
or take a few small yeah and they
literally show it as this like kind of
it's like they lifted out this
topographical map portion and put it on
this blank space and you're moving
around you get three units three mechs
that you can you unlock those as you're
going but then you get to mix and match
them and then you're fighting aliens
that are Vader earth or sorry coming up
from underground and you're not only
protecting your own units or using them
to kind of sacrifice against the aliens
you're also protecting the surrounding
populace and that factors in over the
course of your campaign if you lose
enough civilians or if like certain
amount of power generators get destroyed
by the aliens or the bugs
then you lose but the amount of thought
that goes into each move in that game
and the way that it kind of unfolds
throughout there is procedural
generation it's like a roguelike
elements but the amount of times that I
actually thought I like had it in my
grasp and I was gonna beat the game and
all sudden things just fell apart it's
it's amazing to see it like unfold over
time what stood out to me most was how
complex the game is while still being
very simple and easy to pick up and easy
to do like a I don't know just to run
through I ended up spending like hours
playing it I was just gonna play it for
a little bit to test it out and I was
shortly addicted definitely one of those
games that I'm gonna be excited to play
handheld yeah that's probably my outside
of Monster Hunter that might be my
biggest recommendation and I'm still
playing that whereas I'm not playing
Monster Hunter which there you can't
compare the two games but it's so easy
to just pick up into the breach and play
like half an hour and get your butt
kicked or do well hopefully talk about
games that are easy to pick up I think
Dragon Ball fighters kind of fell into
that category
it's a fighting game that has a lot of
depth there's no doubt about that like
it's highly competitive but it's also
the input system was very simple and the
sort of payoff you got for doing these
very easy to pull up special moves was
great especially if you're a fan of
Dragon Ball Z I mean that is kind of the
point of this game really but no other
Dragon Ball Z game has ever captured the
show the way fighters does it's just art
direction alone and that game is an
execution yeah and the execution of it
is is so phenomenal like even I mean you
have the figure that they're called
right now the finishing moves when you
you get like a scene from the special
finishes yeah they look almost frame to
frame I can't emphasize that enough how
cool that was and I just thought that
like there's little Easter eggs like
that but it really
[Music]
as someone who really likes like
NetherRealm speed fighting games it took
me a little bit to get into Dragonball
Fighters not to get into it but it's not
like I mean obviously it's gorgeous just
looking at as the team that did like
guilty gear that I love that animation
and the art styled by it so far more
fast paced fluid ki reactionary thing
and well liked it was so easy to pick up
but then like again like you have
mentioned like into the breach being
simple but finding depth in that right
that's kind of a subversion that happens
when I play Dragon Ball fighters I will
never understand why the people love you
so Leander weak insipid man but love you
they do without you I would be nothing
that is what they whisper is it not the
other game that really stood out to me
this year was ninokuni - I was a big fan
of the first so I was definitely looking
forward to this one and while I don't
know if I like I think the story in the
first is a bit better I still think this
has everything you could want out of a
game like this and plus it has more I
think the kingdom building is a great
aspect that you don't have to do if you
don't want but if that is something
you're into then there is so much there
and the combat I think has vastly
improved over the first one they chose a
more real-time approach as opposed to a
almost sort of turn-based style in the
first one
I highly recommend I still think about
that game a lot
I don't really care that much about the
first ninokuni I think I played four or
five hours of what is it wrath of the
white witch and then with revenant
Kingdom I absolutely got super into it
also like I love that if you that game
is so despite its art style and like ex
Studio Ghibli Ghibli people working on
it I love that that game is actually
super subtly political the first region
you go to you are the president of you
right yeah let's be clear about that
yeah you play as well one of you can't
play as role in the president of United
States but then of like the main
character I'd say or like the king is
Evan you're the first reason you help
out you would get into it for their
resources the trees from their forest
for the wood to build your revenant
Kingdom but then you get sucked into
like their civil war and their problem
with this puppet state it's actually
kind of again the story is not amazing
but the stuff that they sort of they
subtly hide in this like charming story
was kind of actually surprising I like
the little Lisa Simpson looking dude
yeah I hate him
he's so good peers in every scene he's
just there he's got this very very
abrasive accent play Japanese be already
doing yeah where is it of course I'm
sure there are a lot of people whose
favorite games didn't get mentioned and
like it was a lot of games that we
really liked that we did not mention yet
and a lot of had great games to come out
this year so we want to wrap it fire
them off ugly oh dear
okay what did you guys think of Celeste
really good hard very good very good
all right what about Shadow of the
Colossus remake because I guess yes that
came out this year yes fantastic
it was awesome that's one of the best
games ever made it they have to a for
ps4 could play it only mike has feelings
what what go play shadow Colossus
what is this labo it love it was
interesting and I'm excited to try it
with Mario Kart labo is like a tool to
be creative more than it is like I
gained its own right because the games
it comes with aren't like things that'll
hold you but I do think toy congress is
pretty cool and i really would have
liked it as a child and i
hey that's my piece right that's labo
what about suited hates you
yeah I like despite that games many
flaws and how boring it can be i really
like i know i'll i cannot recommend that
game become human
i think as far as David cage games go I
think Detroit did a lot of good work
with the mechanics of those styles of
Gator and I just think like I really
like Conor's sections yeah but there are
so many like tonal missteps in that game
that you like if you want to enjoy it
you literally said it'd be like this is
Martin Luther King jr. I'm just not
gonna think about it oh yeah there's
scenes that I thought were great and
then there were most of the scenes I
thought were really boring and I wanted
to enter Frost pond I think I'll let you
play for us bunk I love Frost punk yeah
it's fantastic it's same developer as
this war of mine it's very good at
showing how you can accidentally or on
purpose become a dictator in this really
arctic harsh landscape and it's all
based around realtime strategy and heat
not much combat but there is a lot of
decisions there to like generate heat at
the expense of people's well-being
yeah put kids to work stop okay
you should battle tech I love battle
tech as well I'm not really into Mexican
is very very there's a high learning
curve to get into an extremely yeah
patience curve as well yeah yeah red
strings Club I like this one I like this
one a lot it's it has a very good art
style it's almost like a narrative or a
walking simulator no it's almost like a
visual novel you're making decisions as
you go but it has a really cool
cyberpunk style
[Music]
all right well those are our favorite
games throughout the year as well as a
few that we really liked but didn't get
the time to talk about until then go
play Florence I'm gonna do that
[Music]